ein stern heißt den bruder von baker
dinge hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video
dieses video ist eine verdammt schwere
geburt muss ich sagen ich habe das ganze
video eigentlich schon fertig gedreht es
war ganz lustig auch wenn die ganzen
produkte ist nicht so gut mit mir
gemeint haben ich habe das letzte
produkt ausprobiert das musste ich in
die steckdose stecken
und warum auch immer ist im ganzen haus
die sicherungen raus geflogen mein ton
nehme ich ja immer noch zusätzlich über
das imac auf den weg ein mac aus ton
gelöscht video am arsch kann man so ganz
gut zusammen passen auf jeden fall mache
ich das jetzt noch mal und das ist
natürlich immer das schlimmste was
passieren kann weil jetzt habe ich das
alles schon mal gemacht und ich muss das
jetzt praktisch so ein bisschen nach
stellen meine reaktion aber gut es geht
nicht an dass auf jeden fall geht es
heute um essens produkte die dein essen
vereinfachen sollen ich habe ja im
letzten video gesagt dass als nächstes
auf jeden fall wieder essens videos
kommen als nächstes kommt jetzt auch im
ersten video also wo ich wirklich essen
esse und beste usw
allerdings geht es heute nochmal ein
paar coole gadgets die ich bestellt habe
im internet und ich würde sagen will
aber gar nicht lange lass mir sehr gern
nach oben da ich bin auf jeden fall
schon wieder fertig weil leute als
erstes produkt haben wir den
unglaublichen crunch cup zu nehm ich
leider sagen muss dass er nicht da das
setzt dem ganzen eigentliche krone auf
ich war nämlich bis heute morgen noch in
köln habe die ganzen produkte hier
hingestellt und wenn keiner zu hause ist
werden die immer hinters also die werden
irgendwo hingelegt werden wenn ich jetzt
den ort sagen laut meines bruders hat
der postbote die sachen aber vor die
haustür gelegt was er von der arbeit kam
hat er nur ein paket dort aufgefunden
es sollten aber wohl zwei geliefert
worden seien und das ist zwar einfach
weg das heißt irgendwann hat es
anscheinend mit genau dieser dumme cross
cup ist jetzt halt wo auch immer also
zumindest nicht bei mir aber das ist gar
kein problem wir machen einfach weiter
mit dem nächsten produkt und haben wir
den one click stick butter schneider wer
kennt es nicht die butter ist ziemlich
fest und ziemlich kalt und ziemlich hart
und man kriegt ihr nicht aufs brötchen
deswegen habe ich ihn einfach mal für 18
euro 65 bestellt
und ihnen halt eben auch schon einmal
ausprobiert es ist so dumm
hier haben wir ihm also ich habe ihnen
eben halt ausgepackt das brauche ich
jetzt nicht noch mal tun hier ist ein
toastbrot ich erkläre ich das gerät mal
eben weil ich bin ja praktisch ein profi
auf dem gebiet man muss das so ein
bisschen schütteln und dann kommt hier
nämlich oben dieser wasser pusher raus
also dass der putsch die mutter dann
nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal ein neues
stück butter und können dieses hier oben
reinstecken sagt also die mutter war
ziemlich hart weil sie halt gerade aus
dem kühlschrank kommen und dann kommt
der butter pusa wieder oben drauf deckel
drauf und der sinn dieser sache ist dass
man die butter ist in so schönen dünnen
scheiben sich praktisch aufs brot machen
kann oder so das problem ist halt nur
ich weiß schon dass verklebt sich hier
alles also hier klebt alles zu mit
diesen bringen
ich hatte wirklich gebt euch das mal so
ich hatte eben wirklich extrem feste
harte butter und bei der hat das auch
nicht funktioniert das ding hat auch
keine gute bewertungen und mein fazit
eben war das für ein arsch ist ja muss
ich ganz klar so sagen also ich hab mir
davon mehr erhofft ich dachte so wie es
auf dem foto aussieht dass es wirklich
gut funktionieren kann aber die realität
hat dann was anderes gezeigt deswegen
kann ich euch dieses produkt leider
nicht empfehlen auch wenn es cool
aussieht dass muss man ja sagen aber
bild und leute ich schmeiß die butter
natürlich nicht weg die welt noch
verwendet weil gleich kommen freunde von
mir und wir kochen ein bisschen da kann
man das gut verwenden mir kommen zum
nächsten produkt ich gegen ende leute
als nächstes haben wir hier den einer
knacker schaffner also da habe ich mir
eben auch schon die frage gestellt wer
braucht sowas weil selbst ich und ich
bin ein amateur kann einfach auf
schlagen auf einer kante zack läuft aber
für die die das nicht können gibt es
natürlich hier den eier knapp 15 euro
hat er gekostet okay ich habe natürlich
schon mal ausprobiert und auch
ausgepackt so sieht das ganze aus
ja ist auch ein ziemlich einfaches
prinzip du legst hier einfach eine rein
dann drückt sie braucht und das ei wird
geknackt und halt genau in der mitte
zertrennt so dass halt dann die schale
kaputtgeht eben habe ich schon ein
zertrümmerter das muss ich jetzt leider
noch mal machen um euch das zu zeigen
das tut mir sehr sehr leid aber was soll
ich machen also wir verwenden die auf
jeden fall versprochen so und jetzt
passt mal auf das alb kommt hier rein
sagt ich hatte eben absolut angst dass
das
auseinander fest aber das tut es
tatsächlich nicht wir drücken langsam
hier drauf und diese spitze borg sich
jetzt da so rein
ganz vorsichtig mit gefühl oh ich weiß
der scheiße sagt jetzt geht doch sagt
okay und jetzt kann man das auseinander
reizen und hat dann halt das einer raus
und kann das denn jetzt im müll bringen
moment hat funktioniert ist keine schale
obwohl jetzt haben wir ein kleines stück
schadet und das natürlich nicht so
leicht eben hat es ohne geklappt weil
sie ihr könnt eure meinung zu den dingen
in die kommentare schreiben
ich hab so was auf jeden fall noch nie
gesehen und an sich wenn man viele eier
am tag knacken muss macht das vielleicht
sinn aber wir sind ja auch alle kein
bäcker oder gibt es unter euch becker
leider ist auch egal wir machen weiter
mit dem nächsten produkt und das ist
folgendes ich muss sagen wir in
deutschland können damit wahrscheinlich
nicht ganz so viel anfangen wobei ist ja
auch schon doch die eine oder andere
dose oder eine oder andere flasche gibt
die man zerdrücken kann ich habe das
jetzt einfach noch mal eingepackt damit
ein bisschen cooler wir wir haben ja auf
jeden fall den weg rascher ja warte ich
komme ok
das habe ich jetzt nicht ganz gedeckt
der postbote war grad wieder da also
jetzt gerade haben schon ganz schön spät
und meint ja irgendwie blöd das falsch
zugestellt also nicht bei mir und jetzt
hab ich's bekommt also dass es jetzt
tatsächlich dieser crunch cup okay ist
ja gar nicht so schlecht denn lege ich
erst mal zur seite wir sind hier auf
jeden fall eine flasche was halt auch
absolut dumm ist also so sieht das gerät
aus ich habe mich eben über das ding
aufgeregt das problem war nur ich hatte
mir extra noch eine dose hier gelassen
zum verpressen ach komm ich habe ja das
alte material noch check dass hier immer
ab vielleicht ist der ton nicht ganz so
gut aber ich zeige euch dass das
halbwegs funktioniert hat ich habe mir
hier mal kurz eine lose besorgt da ist
fand auf mit uns auch ein bisschen leid
aber wir müssen das einfach mal
demonstrieren
ich weiß ganz genau was viele fragen
jetzt wieder sagen werden du bist so
dumm dass league für heute nicht an mir
die produkte sind scheiße ich meinen
ersten das sieht auf den fotos hier viel
leichter aus als es ist das ist nicht so
leicht und lose zu zerquetschen
ich habe ja auch ein foto gesehen damit
eine flasche zerquetscht das können wir
allerdings noch kurz testen ich bin
sofort wieder da na gut also wenn man
halt irgendwas klein machen will
das ist jetzt das hat sich jetzt schon
vor
also das ist einfach scheiß junge das
hat sie jetzt verboten
guck mal das würde jetzt schon so
abgerutscht was habe ich denn heute für
ein stern weiß dinge so ich glaube er
hat es gesehen trotzdem muss ich sagen
dass ich euch das produkt an sich nicht
empfehlen kann weil ja es ist irgendwie
dann kann es auch einmal auf die dose
drauf springen geht viel leichter also
es ist halt wirklich so traurig ich habe
mir so ausgemalt war das wird ein geiles
video du zeigst den leuten richtig coole
gadgets die deren essen vereinfachen und
im endeffekt ist es alles so der größte
scheiß weil jetzt kommen wir
ich weiß gar nicht ich kann das video
eigentlich gar nicht so nennen wir es
nennen wollte weil das alles halt total
nach hinten los geht auf jeden fall habe
ich noch bestellt das kona
corona waffe kapoor maker dingen das
wurde mir einfach bei amazon
vorgeschlagen und ich dachte mir sowas
kann man immer gebrauchen du machst
damit halt so kleine waffe cups da
kannst du alles rein führen also
irgendwie eine soße oder halt auch eis
was vielleicht gibt es ja alle
möglichkeit dann habe ich eben dieses
teil und nimm die steckdose gesteckt und
ich weiß nicht warum
ganz versicherungen sind raus gesetzt
ich hab's allerdings jetzt geschafft so
kaps zu machen habe auch vorher teig
angerührt ich stecke das ding jetzt aber
nirgendwo mehr rein also in die
steckdose h witzig weil ich habe angst
dass dann wieder in sicherungen raus
fliegen also auch zu den dingen muss ich
sagen da vorsichtig stellt euch das
besser nicht und hier zeige ich euch
jetzt mal die waffe kapsel leute dieses
gerät ist dafür verantwortlich dass hier
andauernd die sicherungen raus geflogen
sind deswegen stelle ich das jetzt nicht
wieder ein auf jeden fall habe ich
einmal geschafft damit diese cups zu
machen aber ich kann euch auch dass sich
empfehlen also diese 21 live aus ich
will jetzt auch mal probieren weil
gewalt aber was wirklich besonderes ist
das jetzt auch nicht ich muss wirklich
sagen dieses video ist ein leichter
flott tut mir echt leid ich hoffe ihr de
abonniert mich nicht dass wir ihn
trotzdem lieber ganz kurz ein schöner
ausschnitt von dem strasser tel agile
hin mehr cups
ich muss jetzt gerade mal überlegen wie
man das dann am besten macht die
waffenschmiede berufung noch eine
himbeere reaktion zeit wird man schon
ganz schön dieses dumme waffel cup
bringen oft versicherungen fliegen das
kann ja nicht nur hier sozusagen das ja
wahrscheinlich ebenso aber leute die ihr
sind wirklich extrem lecker ok also
eigentlich wäre das video jetzt schon
beendet aber das produkt jetzt hier
angekommen ist machen was wenigstens auf
das will ich jetzt noch machen leute ich
sag einfach mal wir machen auf jeden
fall noch im zweiten part wenn ihr bock
drauf habt lasst mir sehr genau auf die
daumen nach oben da weil ich habe leider
keine zutaten dafür eingekauft ich
dachte das ding wir halt eben deswegen
kann ich das jetzt nicht so wirklich
tasten ich hoffe trotzdem dass ihr ein
bisschen spaß hattet beim versagen der
produkte in diesem video zuzuschauen war
es jetzt richtiges deutsch der nächste
party von wird auf jeden fall besser
glaube ich zumindest ich will sich das
wasser nicht versprechen das fazit ist
auf jeden fall wenn ihr irgendwas essen
wollt macht einfach so weiter wie bisher
sucht euch nicht irgendwelche gadgets
mit denen das leichter geht weil im
endeffekt tut es das nicht
zumindest bei diesem schrott ihren
abonniert den kanal freitag gibt es
schon das nächste video
höchstwahrscheinlich steckt auch meinen
neuen kanal palexpo danke fürs zuschauen